This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Seemingly every other month, we hear about the latest example of a thousand year flood, a hundred year hurricane, the once in a lifetime forest fire. Oh my God, I'm a God, I'm a God, I'm a God, I'm a God. The road is on fire. Fire in Oregon, just one of 70 wildfires raging across 12 states. Portland, 116 degrees. That is a new well time record.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。似乎每隔一个月，我们就会听到关于千年一遇的洪水、百年一遇的飓风、一生难得一见的森林大火的最新报道。天哪，我是上帝，我是上帝，我是上帝，我是上帝。道路着火了。俄勒冈州的大火，仅仅是席卷12个州的70场野火之一。波特兰，116华氏度。这是一个新的高温纪录。
I mean, we've never seen anything like this in the Pacific Northwest. Historica catastrophic flooding in Western Europe with at least 199 people killed in hundreds more still missing after violence. Experts have attributed the extreme weather to climate change. The impact of climate change.
我的意思是，我们在太平洋西北地区从未见过这样的景象。西欧发生了历史性的灾难性洪水，在暴力事件后，至少有199人死亡，数百人仍然失踪。专家们将这种极端天气归因于气候变化。气候变化的影响。
No one is immune to climate change. The impact of climate change, no one is immune from climate change. Whenever a climate-related disaster strikes, policy makers and environmentalists issue a call to arms. Here's activist Greta Thunberg. Right here, right now, is where we draw the line. The world is waking up and change is coming Tuneberg. And here is former Vice President, Al Gore. This is our generations' life or death battle.
没有人能免受气候变化的影响。气候变化的影响，没有人能免受气候变化的影响。每当气候相关灾难发生时，政策制定者和环保主义者就会发出战斗号召。这是活动家格蕾塔·通贝里。就在此时此地，我们要划清界限。世界正在觉醒，变革即将到来。还有前副总统阿尔·戈尔。这是我们这一代人的生死之战。
Think back through the histories of the cities represented here and the nations they are found in times in the past where heroism made the difference in a crucial battle that defined history. The whole world is facing just those circumstances right now. By now we have grown accustomed to thinking of climate change as the enemy we must urgently defeat. Year after year, policymakers tell us it is our last and final chance to overcome the crisis. In my view, we've already waited too long to deal with this climate crisis. We can't wait any longer.
回想一下这里所代表的城市及其所在国家的历史，过去曾有英雄主义在决定历史的关键战役中发挥作用的时刻。全世界现在正面临着同样的情况。到目前为止，我们已经习惯于将气候变化视为我们必须紧急击败的敌人。年复一年，政策制定者告诉我们，这是我们克服危机的最后机会。在我看来，我们处理这场气候危机已经等待太久了。我们不能再等了。
The implication here is that while it is late, it is not too late to head off catastrophe. But in many parts of the world, this is no longer true. Celebel rises a reality that's not going to be avoided by eliminating CO2 or methane emissions. This week on Hidden Brain, how to fight the inevitable. When we talk about climate change, we often talk about it as a battle. If we win this battle, we get to avoid catastrophe. If we lose the battle, we get to avoid catastrophe. If we lose the battle, we are finished. Now some battles are like that, but others are not.
这里的含义是，虽然时间已经很晚，但要阻止灾难还为时不晚。但在世界许多地方，这已不再是事实。海平面上升是一个无法通过消除二氧化碳或甲烷排放来避免的现实。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，探讨如何应对不可避免之事。当我们谈论气候变化时，我们经常把它当作一场战斗。如果我们赢了这场战斗，我们就能避免灾难。如果我们输了这场战斗，我们就完了。现在，有些战斗是这样的，但有些则不然。
Today we start with an account of two actual battles, which illustrate two strategies for how we might respond to the huge challenge posed by climate change. Both battles represented crucial moments during the Second World War, but they could not be more different in terms of strategy, tactics, and philosophy. On June 6, 1944, more than 150,000 Allied troops approached the coast of Normandy, a region in the north of France. The invasion fleet is moving towards France. Some 13,000 paratroopers flying in a thousand planes landed behind enemy lines.
今天，我们从两场真实的战役开始，它们阐述了我们应对气候变化巨大挑战的两种策略。这两场战役都代表了第二次世界大战中的关键时刻，但在战略、战术和哲学方面却截然不同。1944年6月6日，超过15万盟军部队接近法国北部诺曼底海岸。入侵舰队正向法国移动。约1.3万名伞兵乘坐一千架飞机降落在敌后。
The area and amphibious assault was the result of months of planning and involved one of the most complex operations in military history. The risks were enormous. And reinforcements arrived, thousands of men. The Normandy invasion came with massive costs. 10,000 soldiers were killed in the battle. But the reason for the sacrifice was clear. This was the way to defeat the Third Reich, to destroy Adolf Hitler.
这次两栖攻击是数月计划的结果，涉及军事史上最复杂的行动之一。风险是巨大的。增援部队抵达了，成千上万的人。诺曼底登陆付出了巨大的代价。1万名士兵在战斗中阵亡。但牺牲的原因很明确。这是击败第三帝国、摧毁阿道夫·希特勒的方法。
to defeat the Third Reich, to destroy Adolf Hitler. D-Day, as a Normandy landing came to be called, became the turning point in the war, and it's a powerful metaphor for one kind of battle. In the face of an existential threat, the Allies mustered the will and the courage to overcome the powerful German war machine. Today, D-Day is still celebrated as one of the greatest military achievements in history. But consider another battle fought four years earlier. The date was May 26, 1940 and the location was farther north on the French coast at a small seaport called Dunkirk.
击败第三帝国，摧毁阿道夫·希特勒。诺曼底登陆（D-Day）成为了战争的转折点，它是某种战斗的有力隐喻。面对生存威胁，盟军鼓起意志和勇气，克服了强大的德国战争机器。今天，诺曼底登陆仍被誉为历史上最伟大的军事成就之一。但请考虑四年前进行的另一场战役。日期是1940年5月26日，地点在法国海岸更北端的一个叫敦刻尔克的小海港。
German forces had overrun France and cut off Allied escape routes. Some 390,000 French and British troops were pinned against the sea. Their supplies were dwindling. They were facing aerial bombardments from Nazi warplanes. And German troops were just outside Dunkirk. The situation was desperate. Their warnaut and footsaw, their hungry, for weeks they have been shielded and bombed from three sides.
德军已经占领了法国并切断了盟军的撤退路线。约39万法英联军被困在海边。他们的补给正在减少。他们面临着纳粹战机的空中轰炸。而德军就在敦刻尔克外围。局势十分绝望。他们精疲力竭，饥肠辘辘，几周来一直受到三面夹击和轰炸。
They had to stagger back to the siege as a vibe. They were betrayed. At stake at Dunkirk was more than just the outcome of a single battle. If the Germans captured this enormous fighting force, it could make the war unwinnable for the Allies. What followed over the next couple of weeks was as remarkable a story as the Allied invasion of Normandy four years later.
他们不得不踉跄着退回到海边。他们被出卖了。敦刻尔克面临的不仅仅是一场战斗的结果。如果德国人俘虏了这支庞大的作战部队，可能会使盟军无法赢得战争。接下来的几周里发生的事情，与四年后盟军入侵诺曼底一样，是一个非凡的故事。
English naval vessels backed by an extraordinary flotilla of fisherman's boats sailed to the French coast to rescue the Maroon troops. In these scenes of the beaches of Dunkirk, you have one of the dramatic pictures of the war. Men waiting out to a vessel beached at Lothide, it's true waiting to haul them aboard. As the Nazis closed in, the boats began ferrying the trapped soldiers across the English
英国海军舰艇在非凡的渔船船队的支援下，航行到法国海岸营救被困部队。在敦刻尔克海滩的这些场景中，你看到了战争中最具戏剧性的画面之一。士兵们涉水走向搁浅的船只，等待被拉上船。随着纳粹的逼近，船只开始将受困士兵运送到英吉利海峡的安全地带。
channel to safety. Sailing with one of the relieving vessels, we pass ship after ship, packed with men whom the long arm of the Royal Navy has brought off the beaches of Dunkirk. Every kind of small craft, destroyers, paddle steamers, yachts, motor boats, rain boats have sped here to the burning ruins of Dunkirk
海峡的安全地带。乘坐其中一艘救援船，我们经过一艘又一艘挤满人的船只，他们是皇家海军从敦刻尔克海滩救出来的。各种各样的小型船只，驱逐舰、明轮船、游艇、摩托艇、划艇，都疾驰到敦刻尔克燃烧的废墟中。
to bring off the Gallant British and French troops. The Belgian fishing fleet evacuated more than 4,000 troops. A paddle steamer, one of those cruise boats with a rotating wheel on one end, made seven round trips and saved 7,000 men. The smallest fishing boat to help with the operation was the Tamzin. It was less than 15 feet long. The story of that epic withdrawal will live in history, both as a glorious example of
去救出英勇的英法联军。比利时渔船队撤离了超过4000名士兵。一艘明轮船，那种一端有旋转轮的游船，往返七次，救出了7000人。参与行动的最小渔船是“塔姆津”号。它不到15英尺长。那次史诗般的撤退故事将载入史册，既是纪律的辉煌典范，也是对……的纪念。最终，被困在敦刻尔克的数十万士兵获救了。他们后来成为了盟军对抗希特勒战争努力的中坚力量。然而，敦刻尔克很难被称为一场胜利。这是一次战略撤退，最终为诺曼底登陆铺平了道路。我希望你在听故事的其余部分时，记住敦刻尔克和诺曼底的故事。
discipline and as a monument to seepah. In the end, hundreds of thousands of men trapped at Dunkirk were saved. They would go on to form the backbone of the Allied war effort against Hitler. Dunkirk could hardly be called a victory, though. It was a strategic retreat, one that would eventually pave the path to the Normandy invasion. I want you to keep the stories of Dunkirk and Normandy in mind as you listen to the rest of the story.
在战略和哲学上，这些战役是我们应对气候变化的两种截然不同方式的隐喻。气候变化故事的一个版本说，如果我们调动所有的努力和资源，团结一致、坚定不移地战斗，我们就能克服可怕的敌人并取得胜利。这个故事说我们正处于诺曼底。许多活动家喜欢诺曼底那种激昂的语言，因为胜利和失败的故事能激励人们采取行动。
In strategy and philosophy, these battles are metaphors for two very different ways we might confront climate change. One version of the climate change story says if we marshal all of our effort and resources and fight with unity and determination we can overcome a terrible foe and win. This story says we are at Normandy. Many activists like the rousing language of Normandy, because stories of victory and defeat exhort people to action.
但气候变化故事的另一个版本说，我们不在诺曼底。我们在敦刻尔克。如果我们想生存，我们需要对我们所面临的困难保持现实，并考虑什么是可行的。在敦刻尔克击败纳粹是不可行的。唯一的选择是想办法撤退并尽可能多地挽救生命。那么，在对抗气候变化的斗争中，哪种隐喻更贴切？如果我们足够努力，胜利是否就在眼前？还是我们应该为了长期生存而接受有条件的失败？
But another version of the climate change story says, we are not at Normandy. We are at Dunkirk. If we want to survive, we need to be realistic about what we are up against and consider what is feasible. Defeating the Nazis at Dunkirk was not feasible. The only option was to figure out how to retreat and save as many lives as possible. So in the struggle against climate change, which metaphor is more fitting? Is victory around the corner if we just try hard enough? Or should we accept a conditional defeat in the service of long-term survival?
当我问自己这些问题时，我知道我想听到什么。我想听到胜利是可能的。如果我们足够努力，我们就能阻止灾难。我叫克里斯蒂娜·希尔，我是加州大学伯克利分校的教授，我教授环境规划和城市设计。克里斯蒂娜专门研究气候变化中最明显的方面之一，也是我们今天主要关注的话题。海平面上升。她说，预计未来80年海洋将至少上升三英尺。但当我们观察世界不同地区可能的极端情况时，
When I ask myself these questions, I know what I want to hear. I want to hear that victory is possible. That if we work hard enough, we can head off catastrophe. My name is Kristina Hill, and I'm a professor at University of California at Berkeley and I teach in environmental planning and urban design. Christina specializes in one of the most visible aspects of climate change and the topic will be mostly focusing on today. Sea level rise. She says the oceans are predicted to go up at least three feet over the next 80 years. But when we look at the possible extremes, in different parts of the world,
例如，罗德岛州已经采纳了到2100年上升约10英尺的预期。加利福尼亚州已经采纳了10英尺2英寸的规划预期，作为2100年的最坏情况。所以有很多关于这个的讨论，但极端情况大约是10英尺，而中等范围更像是4到6英尺之间。在4英尺时，迈阿密劳德代尔堡地区的大部分都在水下。在6英尺时，曼哈顿下城、布鲁克林和纽瓦克的部分地区被淹没。
for example, the state of Rhode Island has adopted an expectation for 2100 of about 10 feet. The state of California has adopted a 10-foot, 2-inch planning expectation as a worst-case scenario for 2100. So there's a lot of discussion about that, but the extreme scenario is about 10 feet and then the mid-range is more like between 4 and 6. At 4 feet, much of the Miami Fort Lauderdale area is underwater. At six feet, parts of Lower Manhattan, Brooklyn, and Newark are submerged.
在10英尺时，圣地亚哥、西雅图和波士顿的大片地区就完了。那种极端情况发生的可能性有多大？很难预测，但估计范围从五十分之一到两百分之一不等。假设正确答案是百分之一。这比我们大多数人想象的要遥远得多。克里斯蒂娜说，她有时很难向学生解释这种风险到底意味着什么。我觉得我总是在处理这种偏见，我们看着
At 10 feet, big swatts of San Diego, Seattle, and Boston are toast. How likely is that extreme scenario? It can be hard to predict, but estimates range from one in 50 to one in 200. Let's say the correct answer is one in 100. That is much less remote than most of us imagine. Christina says she sometimes has trouble explaining to her students exactly what such a risk entails. I feel like I am always working with this kind of bias we have looking at
概率，一种民间的或日常版本的概率论，人们把1%或5%的数字在脑海中变成了零。这意味着什么，我通常在与公众或学生交谈时会用一个例子。如果你曾经在美国见过一个身高5英尺10英寸的女性，那概率是1%。哇。所以这并不罕见。我们大多数人都见过高个子女性。
probability of sort of a folk or everyday version of probability theory where people take a 1% number or a 5% number and they make that zero in their minds. What that means, there's an example I usually use when I'm talking to the public or to my students. If you've ever met a woman in the United States, who's five foot ten, that has one percent odds. Wow. So it's not that unusual. I'm most of us have met tall women.
让我们像克里斯蒂娜的学生一样思考片刻，告诉自己1%的风险等于零。10英尺海平面上升的极端情况在未来几十年内不会发生。海平面上升4-6英尺的可能性有多大？我认为中等范围的可能性更像是60%，我相信在50%到60%之间。我明白了。所以这比抛硬币好一点，但并没有好多少。是的。
Let's think for a moment like Christina's students, and tell ourselves that a one percent risk is the same as zero. That the extreme scenario of ten feet of sea level rise will not come to pass within the next few decades. How likely is a 4-6 foot rise in sea levels? I think that that mid-range is more like 60% probability, between 50 and 60% I believe. I see. So that's a little better than a flip of a coin, but it is not that much better. Yeah.
3-4英尺的海平面上升对世界各国意味着什么？嗯，这太大了。你不需要达到10英尺就会产生巨大的影响。有数亿人生活在那个区域，他们将生活在足够平坦、处于潮汐影响范围之内的地方。让我重复一遍。数亿人。这实际上是一个保守的估计。全世界约有6亿人生活在海岸线上。但有24亿人，约占全球人口的三分之一，
What would 3-4 feet of sea level rise mean for nations around the world? Well, it's huge. You don't have to get the 10 feet to have huge impacts. There are hundreds of millions of people who live in that zone, who will live in places that are flat enough to be within the reach of that tide. who will live in places that are flat enough to be within the reach of that tide. Let me repeat that. Hundreds of millions of people. And that's actually a conservative estimate. About 600 million people worldwide live on the coast. But 2.4 billion people, about a third of the planet's population,
生活在距离海岸60英里的范围内。如果海平面上升冲毁了道路和桥梁，如果它切断了通往医院、机场和学校的通道，水还没有到达你家门口这一事实并不会带来多少安慰。而且这还不包括那些位于潮汐河流上的城市，比如德国的汉堡或华盛顿特区，或者其他潮汐会涌入河流的城市。纵观历史，人类一直在水体旁边建造城市，为了捕鱼、贸易、运输货物和服务以及人员。但上涨的河流可能会危及数千万人，在像
live within 60 miles of a coast. If a rising sea washes out roads and bridges, if it cuts off access to hospitals, airports and schools, the fact that water hasn't yet reached your doorstep will not be much comfort. And that doesn't include the cities that are on tidal rivers, like Hamburg and Germany or Washington, D.C. or other cities where the tide comes up a river. Throughout history, humans have built cities next to bodies of water, to fish, to trade, to transport goods and services in people. But rising rivers could imperil tens of millions of people in places as diverse as
布宜诺斯艾利斯、加尔各答和上海这样多样化的地方。如果你无法通过道路进入你的房产，而且你的下水道可能无法工作，所以你不能冲厕所，人们会感受到这种影响。这是一个非常直接的影响。但我们谈论的是海岸附近的工厂被淹没，供应链被中断。在某种程度上，在经济和交通方面，每个人都会感受到这种海岸变化的影响。我想说，至少就洪水而言，这已经是最糟糕的情况了。不幸的是，情况变得更糟了。
Buenas Aires, Calcutta and Shanghai. If you can't access your property by roads and your sewer lines may not work, so you can't flush the toilet, people are going to feel the impacts of that. That's a very immediate impact. But we're talking about factories and flat areas near the coast being flooded, supply chains, being disrupted. In a way, economically, and in terms of transportation, everyone's going to feel the impact of this coastal change. I'd like to say that at least as far as flooding goes, that's about as bad as it gets. Unfortunately, the story gets worse.
海平面上升不仅仅意味着海洋吞没陆地时的洪水。它还导致了一种不太明显但致命的威胁，即来自地下的地下水位上升。你实际上会看到地下水位的剖面或海拔发生变化，河流中的水量也会发生变化，因为地下水会更多地流向河流，流向海洋，在某些地方实际上会上升到土壤中更高的地方，在大多数地方实际上都是这样。你是说我们已经在美利坚合众国看到了这方面的证据？没错。所以在诺福克、弗吉尼亚州、迈阿密海滩、佛罗里达群岛的高潮时，
Sea level rise doesn't just mean flooding as the ocean swallow up the land. It also leads to a less visible but deadly threat, rising groundwater from below. You'll actually see the profile or elevation of the groundwater table change and the amount of water in rivers change because the groundwater will flow out more towards the river, flow out towards the ocean, and in some places actually come up higher in the soil, in some places actually come up higher in the soil in most places actually. And you're saying we're already seeing evidence of this in the United States? That's right. So at high tides in Norfolk, Virginia, Miami Beach, the Florida Keys,
在这里的旧金山湾，纽约市，人们看到水通过原本设计用来排水的雨水渠涌出来，但现在却让水像喷泉一样冒出来。我的意思是，这听起来几乎像是科幻小说。我的意思是，某种怪物从下水道里冒出来，感觉这就像好莱坞的桥段。它应该被称为“来自地下”。它应该被称为“来自地下”。显而易见，洪水只是气候变化的后果之一。
here in the San Francisco Bay, New York City, people are seeing water come up through storm drains that were designed to take water away, but are now letting water literally bubble up like in a fountain. I mean, it sounds like science fiction almost. I mean, of sort of the monster coming up through the sewer, it feels like it's a Hollywood trope here. It should be called a came from below. It should be called a came from below. Flooding to stay at the obvious is only one of the consequences of climate change.
近几个月来，我们看到了其他影响。飓风、森林大火、极端的天气波动。在许多方面，许多人以类似于盟军看待阿道夫·希特勒的方式看待气候变化，即将其视为必须征服的生存威胁，这并不令人惊讶。而且，许多领导人援引战争语言，暗示如果我们足够努力地战斗，我们就能赢得这场战斗，这也不足为奇。在气候科学的语言中，这种方法被称为减缓。
In recent months, we've seen other effects. Hurricanes, forest fires, extreme swings in weather. In many ways, it's not surprising that many people have come to think of climate change in a way similar to how the Allies thought of Adolf Hitler as an existential threat that must be conquered. And it's not surprising that this leads many leaders to evoke the language of war, to imply that if we only fight hard enough, we can win this battle. In the language of climate science, this approach is known as mitigation.
尽你所能去阻止气候变化。但我与克里斯蒂娜谈话中最令人不安的部分不是她对如果我们不采取行动会发生什么的描述。而是即使我们采取了行动会发生什么的描述。例如，现在预计即使我们今天停止所有人为活动和牲畜排放的每一个二氧化碳分子，海平面上升也会发生。所以，海平面上升，现在，你知道，马已经跑出马厩了，它无论如何都会发生。为什么会这样，克里斯蒂娜？为什么减缓措施不能阻止这个问题？我的意思是，你知道，
Do everything you can to head off climate change. But the most disturbing part of my conversation with Christina was not her account of what could happen if we failed to act. It was a account of what would happen even if we acted. Sea level rise, for example, is now projected to happen even if we stopped every molecule of CO2 from leaving human activities and livestock today. So, sea level rises, and now, you know, the horse that left the barn, it's going to happen anyway. Why is that, Christina? Why would mitigation not head off the problem? I mean, the, you know,
有一句古老的谚语，当你身处洞中时，首先要做的是停止挖掘。而气候变化的类比是，首先要做的是不要让问题比现在更糟。那么为什么停止温室气体排放不能阻止这些即使是中等程度的海平面上升情景呢？嗯，海洋已经吸收了我们过去两三百年排放的大部分二氧化碳。所以我们看到的只是变化
there's the old proverb, the first thing to do when you're in a hole is to stop digging. And the analogy with climate change would be the first thing to do is to not make the problem any worse than it is right now. So why is it that stopping the emissions of greenhouse gases, why would it not head off these even the moderate scenarios of sea level rise? Well, the oceans have absorbed most of the CO2 that we've emitted so far over the last two, 300 years. So we're seeing change just
基于我们300年来犯下的错误。而且我们还看到了仅靠停止二氧化碳排放无法阻止的临界点和融化，因为已经有太多的二氧化碳了。所以这确实说明了系统的惯性，不是吗？没错。我的意思是，我们正在努力追赶。我们已经了解了过去300年我们犯了什么错误，但它已经产生了后果。
based on our 300 years of making this mistake. And we're also seeing tipping points and melting that can't be arrested just by stopping the CO2 emissions because there already is so much CO2. So this really speaks to sort of the inertia of the system, does it not? so much CO2. So this really speaks to sort of the inertia of the system, does it not? That's right. I mean, we're trying to catch up. We've learned about what our mistake was over the last 300 years, but it's already had consequences.
我们必须认识到这些系统已经发生了变化。我的意思是，当你想到关于气候变化是否真实仍然存在争论时，这在某种程度上看起来有点可怕，而你基本上是在说，你知道，在这一点上，气候变化的许多影响几乎是不可避免的。是的，在我们已经居住的新星球上已经注定了。这种说法与我们在谈论应对气候变化时听到的许多内容背道而驰。
We have to recognize that these systems have already changed. I mean, it seems a little scary in some ways when you think that there's still sort of debates ongoing debates about whether climate change is real, and you're basically saying, you know, at this point, many of the effects of climate change are almost inevitable. Yeah, baked in on our new planet that we already live on. This kind of talk runs against so much of what we hear when it comes to fighting climate change.
我们通常被告知我们处于诺曼底，有一种方法可以击败希特勒。克里斯蒂娜说，不，我们在敦刻尔克。我们可能不喜欢我们面对的现实，但我们必须对此保持现实。我们必须为那个现实做好准备，这就是所谓的适应。现在，值得注意的是，这种思维方式可能会令人沮丧。如果我们接受气候变化的某些方面将持续存在，这会使一些
We are usually told we are at Normandy that there is a way to defeat Hitler. Christina is saying, no, we are a Dunkirk. We may not like the reality we confront, but we have to be realistic about it. We have to prepare for that reality, what's known as adaptation. Now, it's worth noting that this type of thinking can be disperting. If we accept that some aspects of climate change are here to stay, will that make some
人撒手不管并放弃吗？政府会撤回他们为控制碳排放所做的微薄承诺吗？气候变化否认者和化石燃料行业会说，你知道吗，现在做任何事情都太晚了，所以何必呢？这些担忧是真实且令人担忧的。但在世界许多地方，重点已经从减缓转向适应。这是因为在这些地方，气候变化不仅仅是未来的理论风险。它是此时此地的生存威胁。
people throw out their hands and give up? Will governments backpedal on even the meager promises they have made to rein in carbon emissions? And will climate change denialists and the fossil fuel industry say, you know what, it's too late to do anything, so why bother? Those concerns are real and worrisome. But in many parts of the world, the focus is already moving from mitigation to adaptation. That's because in these places, climate change isn't just a theoretical risk in the future. It's an existential threat in the here and now.
如果一切照旧，我们将无法生存，我们将死去。我们的国家将不复存在。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当我们思考气候变化的影响时，很难预见我们在未来几十年可能面临的所有风险。但正如作家威廉·吉布森曾经说过的，未来已经到来。只是分布得不太均匀。
risk in the future. It's an existential threat in the here and now. If things go business as usual, we will not live, we will die. Our country will not exist. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When we think about the effects of climate change, it can be hard to anticipate all the risks we may face in the coming decades. But as the author William Gibson once said, the future is already here. It's just not very evenly distributed.
我此刻正站在未来。浅水拍打着我的脚。我在马尔代夫，这是印度洋斯里兰卡海岸外近1200个珊瑚岛组成的群岛。景色令人叹为观止。棕榈树在白色的沙滩上摇曳。海水是绿松石色的。情侣们在躺椅上晒太阳。马尔代夫是名人的磁铁。有些度假村有水下卧室，当你入睡时，可以通过玻璃墙观看五颜六色的鱼。这一切看起来很田园诗般，但实际上这是一部恐怖电影的场景。
I'm standing in the future right now. Shallow water laps at my feet. I'm in the Maldives, a group of nearly 1200 coral islands in the Indian Ocean off the coast of Sri Lanka. The scene is breathtaking. Palm trees sway on white sand beaches. The water is turquoise. Couples tan themselves on lounge chairs. The Maldives are a magnet for celebrities. Some results have underwater bedrooms where you can watch multicolored fish through glass walls as you slip after sleep. It all looks idyllic but it's actually a scene from a horror movie.
哈桑·马尼库多年来一直看着那部电影上演。我们基本上看到了侵蚀，这是最大的事情。大片的海滩被冲入大海。马尔代夫和地球上的每个国家一样，正在努力应对气候变化的影响。但这里的挑战是不同的。这些岛屿位于海洋中央。它们容易受到随气候变化而加剧的恶劣天气模式的影响。
Hassan Manikou has watched that movie unfold over many years. We've seen a erosion basically that's that's the biggest thing. Big area chunks of beach just washing away into the sea. The Maldives, like every nation on Earth, is grappling with the effects of climate change. But the challenges here are different. The islands are in the middle of the ocean. They are vulnerable to harsh weather patterns that have intensified with climate change.
在最近的一个厄尔尼诺季节之后，水温上升了整整4华氏度。马尔代夫超过70%的珊瑚被漂白，变成了难看的灰白色。就珊瑚而言，从我年轻时到现在，与过去相比简直没法比。即使是10年前，我的意思是，它非常丰富多彩，所以现在看到它很悲伤，因为它基本上当你现在去浮潜时，你看到的是死珊瑚和被冲上岸的死珊瑚，漂白的死珊瑚。
After one recent El Nino season, the water temperature rose four whole degrees Fahrenheit. More than 70% of the coral in the Maldives got bleached, turning it into an ugly off-white color. And in terms of coral from when I was younger to what it is now, it's nothing compared to what it was. Even 10 years ago I mean, it was so colorful, so it's it's sad to see it, what it was. Even 10 years ago, I mean, it was so colorful, so it's sad to see it now because it's pretty much when you go snorkeling now, you see dead coral and dead coral washed up, bleached dead coral.
这与我年轻时，也许10、15年前相比有显著不同。垂死的珊瑚和被侵蚀的海滩令人悲伤，但你可能会说它们主要是美学因素。然而，在马尔代夫并非如此。海洋正在威胁整个国家的生存。我认为马尔代夫将是第一批完全沉入水下的岛国之一，
It's significantly different from when I was younger, maybe 10, 15 years ago. Dying coral and eroded beaches are sad, but you might say they're mainly a factorists. That's not true in the Maldives, though. The ocean is threatening the very existence of the entire country. I think Maldives will be one of the first islands, whole island nations to go underwater,
如果海平面确实显著上升。根据一些估计，马尔代夫可能很快就会被上升的海平面淹没。80%的马尔代夫岛屿海拔不到1米或3英尺。正如我们之前听到的，预计到本世纪末，海平面将至少上升那么多。那么像马尔代夫这样的国家该怎么办？2008年，马尔代夫总统穆罕默德·纳希德开始探索一个激进的解决方案，在印度、斯里兰卡或澳大利亚购买土地，并将整个国家迁移到别处。这值得重复。
if sea level does rise significantly. According to some estimates, the Maldives could soon be submerged by rising sea levels. 80% of the Maldivian islands lie less than 1 meter or 3 feet above sea level. As we heard earlier, sea levels are expected to rise by at least that amount by the end of the century. So what's a nation like the Maldives to do? In 2008, the President of the Maldives, Muhammad Nasheed, started to explore a radical solution, buying land in India, Sri Lanka, or Australia, and transplanting his entire nation elsewhere. That bear is repeating.
他开始研究将国家搬到别处需要什么。穆罕默德·纳希德告诉《卫报》，我们不想离开马尔代夫，但我们也不想成为在帐篷里生活几十年的气候难民。2009年，他在联合国发表了讲话。请，女士们先生们，我们没有做任何这些事情，但如果一切照旧，我们将无法生存，我们将死去。
He began to look into what it would take to move his country somewhere else. We do not want to leave the Maldives, Muhammad Nashite told the Guardian, but we also do not want to be climate refugees living in tents for decades. In 2009, he spoke at the UN. Please, ladies and gentlemen, we did not do any of these things, but if things go business as usual, we will not live, we will die.
我们的国家将不复存在。这次演讲是让世界认真对待气候变化的主要外交努力的一部分。在某种程度上，这是一种诺曼底式的战斗号召。但与此同时，他认识到他国家处境的严峻现实。这需要一种敦刻尔克式的撤退。当然，搬迁一个国家不是一件简单的事情。
Our country will not exist. The speech was part of a major diplomatic push to get the world to take climate change seriously. In a way, it was a Normandy style called to arms. But at the same time, he recognized the stark reality of his country situation. It called for a Dunkirk-style retreat. Of course, moving a country is not a simple thing.
马尔代夫人民在这些岛屿上有悠久的历史。一个国家不仅仅是土地，它是历史、语言、美食、习俗。你怎么能就这样收拾行李离开呢？从心理上讲，这对他们来说将是毁灭性的。所以这些也是在迁移人口时需要考虑的事情。你不能只是随心所欲地搬迁人口。要和他们一起搬迁。在马尔代夫，就像在世界其他许多地方一样，
The Moldavian people have a long history on these islands. And a nation is not just land, it's history, it's language, cuisine, customs. How can you just pick up and leave? Psychologically, this would be devastating for them. So these are things that need to be looked at as well when moving people. You can't just move people wherever you feel like. Move with them. In the Maldives, as in many other parts of the world,
字面上遵循敦刻尔克模式并撤离人口是不可行的。但也许我们应该更广泛地看待敦刻尔克隐喻。从本质上讲，它教给我们的是适应我们所面临现实的重要性。盟军在敦刻尔克无法击败纳粹，这对军事领导人来说是一颗难以下咽的苦果。但如果他们不接受这一事实并进行战略撤退，他们可能会输掉整个战争。马尔代夫的人民知道他们无法阻止海洋上升。他们必须适应那个现实。
it is infeasible to literally follow the Dunkirk model and evacuate people. But perhaps we should look at the Dunkirk metaphor more broadly. At its essence, what it teaches us is the importance of adapting to the realities we face. The fact that the Allies couldn't defeat the Nazis at Dunkirk was a bitter pill for military leaders to swallow. But if they didn't come to the terms with that fact and strategically retreat, they could have lost the entire war. People in the Maldives know they cannot stop the ocean from rising. They have to adapt to that reality.
在过去的几年里，这正是他们开始做的事情。好吧，那么请描述一下我们现在在哪里，哈桑。请描述一下我们周围看到的东西以及我们在哪里。我们在一个岛上，它目前正处于被填海的过程中。哈桑和我站在一小片椭圆形的土地上。周围都是巨大的、笨重的船只，上面装载着重型机械。我们在假期参观了这个岛，所以机器很安静。但哈桑解释了它们在这里要做什么。
And over the last several years, that is exactly what they have started to do. Alright, so just describe where we are right now, Hassan. Just describe what we're seeing around us and where we are. We're on an island, which is in the midst of being reclaimed right now. Hassan and I are standing on a small oval spit of land. All around are huge, hulking ships with heavy machinery aboard. We visited the island on a holiday, so the machines were silent. But Hassan explained what they were here to do.
所以我们有挖掘机、挖泥船。我们有很多岩石巨石，最终将为岛屿创造海岸保护。这个特定的岛屿曾经是一个沙洲，我们通过疏浚对其进行了某种程度的增强。我看到那边的机器，那是挖泥船吗？那是挖泥船。那是一艘挖泥船，挖泥船在车辆的前部。你把它放下去，它就会翻动沙子，
So we've got excavators, dredgers. We've got a lot of rock boulders, which will eventually create show protection for the island. This particular island used to be a sandbank, which we have sort of enhanced through Dredging. The machine that I'm seeing over there, that's a Dredger? That's a Dredger. That's a Dredger with sort of the Dredger is on top, on the front of the vehicle. And you put that down and it turns the sand and
通过那些管道将沙子和水疏浚到岛上。那么，疏浚沙子并拉动水，这里的目标是什么，你试图做什么？我们最终试图创造一个岛屿，它将是……我们试图创造一个岛屿。哈桑实际上是从海里提取土地。同样，这不是一个天然岛屿。我们正在一个自然可能需要数百年才能形成岛屿的地区进行填海造陆。
dredges sand plus water through those pipes onto the island. And so what's the idea of sort of dredging up the sand and pulling them the water, what's the goal here, what are you trying to do? We're trying to create an island eventually which will be... We're trying to create an island. Hass which will be... We're trying to create an island. Hasan is literally extracting land from the sea. Again, this is not a natural island. We're reclaiming in an area where naturally it may have taken hundreds of years for an island to form.
我们试图在四五个月内完成它。所以，要么我们住在海洋的浮动结构上，要么我们疏浚并创造高于海平面的土地。这就是现在正在发生的事情。我想我们现在正走到岛的中间。我想我们可能离海平面大约三英尺高。
We're trying to do it within four or five months. So, it's either we live on floating structures in the ocean or we dredge and we create land above the sea level. That's what's happening right now. And so I'm guessing we're sort of walking around now to the about the middle of the island. And I'm guessing we're probably about maybe three feet above sea water, sea level.
我们在两米处。哦，实际上是两米。海平面。我们在两米处。哦，实际上是两米。海拔两米。好的，但现在整个东西都是沙子。整个东西现在都是沙子，是的。整个东西都是建立在沙子上的。沙子足够坚固，可以在上面建造建筑物。这个岛现在看起来不像天堂，
We're at two meters. Oh, it's actually two meters. sea water, sea level. We're at two meters. Oh, it's actually two meters. Two meters above sea level. OK, but the whole thing right now is sand. Holding right now is sand, yeah. The whole thing is built on sand. The sand is strong enough to have buildings on it. This island doesn't look like paradise right now,
但它最终将容纳一个拥有约80间客房的旅游度假村和一个研究气候变化影响的环境科学中心。哈桑是一位开发商，也是一个环境非政府组织的领导人之一。再次强调，为游客建造岛屿的想法并不高尚，但这个岛上发生的事情只是整个国家正在考虑的事情的延伸。马累首都的一个新版本正在从海中填出的土地上崛起。它被称为希望之城。
but it will eventually house a tourist resort with about 80 guest rooms and an environmental science center to study the effects of climate change. Hassan is a developer and also one of the leaders of an environmental NGO. Now again, the idea of building islands for tourists isn't very high-minded, but what's happening on this island is only an extension of what is being considered for the entire country. A new version of the capital city of Male is rising on land reclaimed from the sea. It's being called the city of Hope.
现在第一阶段已经基本完成，有公寓、学校。那里现在有一家最先进的医院，基本上是一个新城市，第二阶段也即将到来，有体育场之类的东西，所以现在正在引入基础设施。所以最终将会有大约四五个相互连接的岛屿网络，它们将组成马尔代夫的首都或首都地区。所以你知道，不仅仅是度假村在创造岛屿，马累政府也基本上在说，为了生存，选择要么把每个人都搬走，要么我们实际上必须搬到更高的地方，没有更高的地方可以搬，所以你实际上必须创造更高的地方。
And now phase one is almost done already with the apartment, schools. There's a state of the yard hospital there now, and basically a new city, and phase 2 is also coming up with like sports stadiums and all that kind of stuff, so just bringing in the infrastructure in now. So eventually there'll be a network of about four or five islands connected to each other which will consist of the capital city or the capital area of Maldives. So you know there's not just the results that are basically having been creating the islands and the government of Mali is also sort of saying for us to basically survive the options are to either move everybody off or we actually have to move to higher ground there is no higher ground to move to so you actually have to create higher ground.
完全正确，完全正确。这就是现在正在发生的事情。我们正在创造更高的地方。我的意思是，如果你从科学角度讲，我们通过上升一米，大约可以多获得150年，100年的时间。这基本上就是他们所采用的想法。你在世界其他处于气候变化前线的地方也看到了同样的情况。这些地方的人们并不专注于击败气候变化或预防它。他们知道那场战斗已经输了。他们谈论的是适应，而不是减缓。在新奥尔良，在卡特里娜飓风于2005年几乎摧毁这座城市后，联邦和地方政府投入了数十亿美元。
Exactly, exactly. That's what's happening right now. We're creating higher ground. I mean, if you speak scientifically, we are getting about 100, say, 50 years more, 100 years more by going up a meter. That's essentially the idea that they're going with. You see the same thing in other parts of the world on the front lines of climate change. People in these places are not focused on defeating climate change or preventing it. They know that battle has already been lost. Instead of mitigation, they are talking adaptation. In New Orleans, after Hurricane Katrina nearly destroyed the city in 2005, federal and local governments invested billions of dollars.
这笔钱的目的不是为了让新奥尔良过渡到可再生能源。它用于建造约350英里的堤坝、泵和闸门，环绕城市。基于这样一个假设，即城市再次遭受毁灭性飓风袭击只是时间问题。16年后，即2021年8月，当艾达飓风袭击路易斯安那州时，仍然存在重大问题，包括数周没有电力。但与卡特里娜飓风相比，死亡人数大大减少，破坏也显著降低。花在适应上的钱可能拯救了新奥尔良。
The money wasn't aimed at transitioning New Orleans to renewable energy sources. It went into building some 350 miles of levees, pumps, and gates, encircling the city. Based on the assumption, it would be only a matter of time before the city was struck by another devastating hurricane. When Hurricane Ida struck Louisiana 16 years later, in August 2021, there were still major problems, including weeks without power. But there were vastly fewer deaths and significantly less destruction compared to Katrina. The money spent on adaptation likely saved New Orleans.
在马尔代夫，哈桑·马尼库预测，他的国家今天所做的事情，世界其他地方明天也会做。而且不仅仅是马尔代夫会沉入水下，曼哈顿的一半也会，所有其他国家的海岸线也会。所以这是一个全球性问题。当然，可怕的讽刺是，像新奥尔良和马尔代夫这样适应气候变化的努力，从长远来看实际上可能会使气候变化变得更糟。疏浚需要大量的化石燃料，并将温室气体泵入空气中，这个过程会损害生物多样性。哈桑看到了这个悖论。
In the Maldives, Hassan Manikul predicted that what his country was doing today, the rest of the world would be doing tomorrow. And it wouldn't be just the Maldives going underwater, it would be half of Manhattan, it would be shorelines of all the other countries as well. So it's a global problem. The terrible irony, of course, is that efforts in places like New Orleans and the Maldives to adapt to climate change might actually make climate change worse in the long run. Dredging requires enormous amounts of fossil fuels and pumps greenhouse gases into the air and the process damages biodiversity. Hassan sees the paradox.
发生的情况是，当你疏浚时，会有大量的淤泥和沙子分散，显然，随着洋流等因素。沙子沉淀在珊瑚礁顶部，破坏了珊瑚，基本上阻止了光合作用的发生。疏浚一点也不环保，我会说。我们正在破坏泻湖，我们正在破坏周围的生态系统，在如此巨大的开发之后，珊瑚礁需要很长时间才能恢复。哈桑的非政府组织正在与麻省理工学院的科学家合作，试图利用自然过程来更
What happens is when you are dredging there's a lot of silt and sand which goes which disperses, obviously, with the currents and things. The sand settles on top of the reef, damaging the corals and basically stopping photosynthesis from happening. Dredging is not environmentally friendly at all, I would say. We're disrupting the lagoon, we're disrupting the ecosystem around here and it takes a long time for the reefs to recover after such a huge development. Hassan's NGO is working with scientists at MIT to try to use natural processes to more
快速地建造像这样的新岛屿。他希望他国家的困境能吸引世界各地的科学家前来研究什么有效，什么无效。哈桑知道的一件事是，在马尔代夫，没有无痛的解决方案。没有最终的胜利。他们处于敦刻尔克。他们需要现实一点，才能在海洋面前领先一步。当我听到哈桑的故事时，我内心的一部分说，好吧，你可以跑赢海洋一年或十年。
quickly build up new islands like this one. He hopes his nation's plight will attract scientists from around the world to come and study what works and what doesn't. The one thing that Hassan knows is that here in the Maldives, there are no pain-free solutions. No final victories. They are at Dunkirk. They need to be realistic to stay one step ahead of the sea. As I heard Hassan's story, there was a part of me that said, okay, you can outrun the ocean for a year or a decade.
但你能永远跑赢它吗？这就是我们回来时要讨论的。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在像马尔代夫这样的地方，人们已经认识到他们不在诺曼底。击败气候变化已不再是议题。在野火、飓风和严重干旱日益频繁的地区，类似的转变正在发生。
But can you outrun it forever? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In places like the Maldives, people have recognized they are not at Normandy. Defeating climate change is no longer on the table. In regions where wildfires, hurricanes and crippling droughts are increasingly regular occurrences, a similar shift is unfolding.
在某些地方，人们被迫拔掉桩子离开，采取敦刻尔克式的撤退。其他人则被迫想出创造性的方法来适应。在热浪期间在城市建立冷却中心，维护健康和有弹性的森林以最大限度地减少野火，在干旱或洪水期间以不同的方式种植作物。具有讽刺意味的是，诺曼底，那个反击的纪念性象征，这些天也处于敦刻尔克模式。由于海平面上升，它正遭受海岸侵蚀。作为回应，当地政府正在适应，建立通往海洋的天然屏障，重新安置
In some places, people have been forced to pull up stakes and leave, Dunkirk style. Others have been forced to come up with creative ways to adapt. Establishing cooling centers and cities during heatwaves, maintaining healthy and resilient forests to minimize wildfires, growing crops differently in periods of drought or flooding. Ironically, Normandy, that monumental symbol of fighting back, is itself in Dunkirk mode these days. It's suffering from coastal erosion due to rising sea levels. And in response, the local government is adapting, building up natural barriers to the sea, relocating
在某些地方，人们被迫像敦刻尔克大撤退那样背井离乡。其他人则被迫想出创造性的方法来适应。比如在热浪期间建立城市避暑中心，维护健康且具有韧性的森林以减少野火，在干旱或洪水期间采用不同的农作物种植方式。具有讽刺意味的是，作为反击的纪念性象征，诺曼底如今也处于“敦刻尔克模式”中。它正遭受海平面上升导致的海岸侵蚀。作为应对，当地政府正在进行调整，建立天然的海上屏障并进行搬迁。
vulnerable houses and farms, and implementing what they call a strategic withdrawal in the face of an advancing sea. From Normandy to the Maldives, many places are just getting started on this journey. But there is one nation that has a long head start on the rest of the world. Here, the problems posed by rising seas are not just a future. They are the present and also the past. That nation is the Netherlands. More than a quarter of the Netherlands is below sea level. Christina Hill, the UC Berkeley scientist we heard from earlier, says that for many hundreds of years, the Dutch have been building long,
脆弱的房屋和农场，并实施他们所谓的面对不断推进的海水时的战略撤退。从诺曼底到马尔代夫，许多地方才刚刚开始这段旅程。但有一个国家比世界其他地方领先了一大截。在这里，海平面上升带来的问题不仅仅是未来，它们是现在，也是过去。那个国家就是荷兰。荷兰超过四分之一的土地低于海平面。我们之前听到的加州大学伯克利分校的科学家克里斯蒂娜·希尔说，几百年来，荷兰人一直在建造长长的、
tall walls to keep out the sea. Force they built dikes around individual villages, and then as regions became kind of realities through political power, they would connect those individual village or city dikes and make them into regional di Dikes? Keeping out the sea water is only the first step though. Remember earlier how we talked about the monster that came from below? The Dutch came up with a solution for that too. The Netherlands has an incredibly extensive system of pumps that controls the groundwater level. And if you don't have that extensive system of pumps,
高大的围墙来抵御海洋。起初，他们在各个村庄周围建造堤坝，然后随着地区通过政治力量形成，他们会将这些独立的村庄或城市堤坝连接起来，使它们成为区域性堤坝。抵御海水只是第一步。还记得我们之前谈到的来自地下的怪物吗？荷兰人也想出了解决办法。荷兰拥有极其庞大的泵系统来控制地下水位。如果你没有那个庞大的泵系统，
then even if you build a dike, the groundwater comes up behind it. This system of pumps and dikes helped to keep both the sea and the groundwater from perpetually flooding their land. The pumps would pipe the water out from the ground and redistributed, while the tall dike walls prevented water from flooding in the first place. These were the solutions that the Dutch needed before climate change started to lead to sea level rise. Now, they're working overtime on new techniques.
那么即使你建造了堤坝，地下水也会从后面涌上来。这套泵和堤坝系统有助于防止海水和地下水持续淹没他们的土地。泵会将地下的水抽走并重新分配，而高大的堤坝墙则首先防止了水涌入。这些是荷兰人在气候变化导致海平面上升之前所需要的解决方案。现在，他们正在加班加点研究新技术。
Yeah, they are planning to expand their sandy coast which has a dune line, and that dune line is the effective barrier between them and the sea. And they're trying to, what they call, build with nature, or imitate nature, by moving huge quantities of sand and dumping it in a spit shape on the shoreline. And by using that natural approach, they can save a lot of money on what they normally do, which would be bulldozers and blowing machines that blow sand up onto the dunes. And it also provides them with recreational benefits because it provides a point break for
是的，他们计划扩大沙质海岸，那里有一条沙丘线，而那条沙丘线是他们与海洋之间的有效屏障。他们正在尝试所谓的“与自然共建”或模仿自然，通过移动大量的沙子并将其以沙嘴的形式倾倒在海岸线上。通过使用这种自然方法，他们可以在通常的做法上节省大量资金，因为通常的做法是使用推土机和吹沙机将沙子吹到沙丘上。而且它还为他们提供了娱乐效益，因为它为
surfing and all kinds of activities in the water. And it provides habitat because they're no longer driving, have you equipment over the beach every year. So that's called the sand engine and that's one of their big innovations which uses natural processes. I mean, at some level, you know, the idea that sort of you can hold the sea at bay, I mean, it's sort of impressive that they've essentially done it for several hundred years, but it also does seem like something of a fool's errand at some point. Now, they've done it for more than a thousand, increasingly concrete and steel away.
冲浪和各种水上活动提供了浪点。它还提供了栖息地，因为他们不再每年都在海滩上驾驶重型设备。所以这被称为“沙引擎”，这是他们利用自然过程的重大创新之一。我的意思是，在某种程度上，你知道，那种你可以将海洋拒之门外的想法，我的意思是，他们基本上已经这样做了几百年，这确实令人印象深刻，但在某种程度上，这似乎也像是一种徒劳。现在，他们已经这样做了超过一千年，越来越依赖混凝土和钢铁。
They're just now kind of moving back to a big-scale version of using sand and earth in new ways. Over time, what choice are they facing as a nation state? It would be to move to Germany. And that's not politically on the table. So they have to keep working at it. And their plan is to continue to innovate and to share what they learn with the rest of the table. So they have to keep working at it, and their plan is to continue to innovate and to share what they learn with the rest of the world.
他们现在正开始回归到以新方式使用沙子和泥土的大规模版本。随着时间的推移，作为一个民族国家，他们面临什么选择？那将是搬到德国。但这在政治上是不可能的。所以他们必须继续努力。他们的计划是继续创新，并与世界其他地方分享他们的经验。所以他们必须继续努力，他们的计划是继续创新，并与世界其他地方分享他们所学到的东西。
If you're thinking the rest of the world should start learning what the Dutch have to teach, there is a major catch. All this adaptation, it costs a lot of money. Few countries are spending anywhere close to what the Dutch are spending, and that goes for the United States too. Some parts of the US are starting to wake up. In September 2021, California approved a $15 billion package for climate change initiatives. That number was a record, but Christina said even that level of spending may not be enough
如果你认为世界其他地方应该开始学习荷兰人的经验，这里有一个主要障碍。所有这些适应措施都需要花费大量的金钱。很少有国家在支出上接近荷兰的水平，美国也是如此。美国的一些地区开始觉醒。2021年9月，加利福尼亚州批准了一项150亿美元的气候变化倡议方案。这个数字创下了纪录，但克里斯蒂娜说，即使是这样的支出水平也可能不足以
for the challenges facing her home state. I asked her to paint me a picture of what the coming decades hold for the San Francisco Bay Area. If sea level rises, let's say three feet, then a lot of the Bay Area shoreline would be inundated. And if it was just the horizontal movement of that salt water, we would build dicks and prevent it from moving laterally. But unfortunately, it's also groundwater. So we have to be able to drain stormwater, and we have to be able to accommodate higher groundwater, and we have to accept that salt water will try to move inland and figure out what we're going to do about that. So a lot of low places, the City of Alameda is an island, East Oakland, San Francisco, the Mission Bay area. If sea level rises above three feet, those areas will be flooded and they may not be able to tolerate the high ground
应对她家乡面临的挑战。我请她描绘一下旧金山湾区未来几十年的景象。如果海平面上升，比如说三英尺，那么湾区的大部分海岸线将被淹没。如果只是海水的水平移动，我们会建造堤坝并防止它横向移动。但不幸的是，还有地下水。所以我们必须能够排放雨水，我们必须能够适应更高的地下水位，我们必须接受海水会试图向内陆移动，并弄清楚我们要对此做些什么。所以很多低洼地区，阿拉米达市是一个岛屿，东奥克兰，旧金山，使命湾地区。如果海平面上升超过三英尺，这些地区将被淹没，它们可能无法承受它们将面临的高地下水。
water that they'll face before that. There are places in the Bay Area where there are radioactive dumping sites, and as the sea level arises in the groundwater, those contaminants will move around, potentially, in the soil. And that's more of an impact on communities of color because they live in lower places. It may already be happening in places around the Bay Area. So the Bay Area could be if we don't find the right way to adapt a big toxic soup within a mile of the shore zone. And it's gonna be very difficult to live next to that
湾区有些地方有放射性垃圾倾倒场，随着海平面和地下水位的上升，这些污染物可能会在土壤中移动。这对有色人种社区的影响更大，因为他们住在地势较低的地方。这可能已经在湾区周围的一些地方发生了。所以，如果我们找不到正确的适应方式，湾区可能会变成一个距离海岸线一英里内的大型有毒汤。住在那里旁边，看着它随着时间的推移慢慢爬上所有的道路和下水道管道，将会非常困难。
and to watch it creeping up all the roads and sewer pipes over time. It's tempting when you hear about this unfolding catastrophe to imagine there must be a way to prevent it from happening. But then Christina presented me with a simple thought experiment. More than anything else she told me, it brought home to me the futility of trying to push back the sea. To imagine we can win a war against climate change. Imagine trying to take three feet off the surface of the ocean
当你听到这场正在展开的灾难时，很容易想象一定有一种方法可以防止它发生。但随后克里斯蒂娜向我提出了一个简单的思想实验。她告诉我的话中，最让我深刻体会到试图抵御海洋的徒劳。想象我们可以赢得一场对抗气候变化的战争。想象一下试图从海洋表面取走三英尺的水，
and store it somewhere when the ocean is 75% plus of the planet's surface. That is not possible. Never mind the energy to pump it into some low place. So we're going to have to live with a huge ocean. That's very powerful and inexorably continuing to rise over time. I think we really should think about living with it
并将其储存在某个地方，而海洋占据了地球表面75%以上的面积。这是不可能的。更不用说将其泵入某个低洼地所需的能量了。所以我们将不得不与巨大的海洋共存。它非常强大，并且随着时间的推移不可阻挡地持续上升。我认为我们真的应该考虑与它共存，
in ways that are productive and safe instead of trying to keep it out. So, this is fascinating what you're saying, because in some ways you're saying sort of the metaphor in some ways of believing that we can overcome this fall, that might be sort of the wrong metaphor, that in some ways that battle might almost have been lost already. That's right, and the ocean has been rising for the last 22,000 years. We just have been in a slow period. We invented this whole city thing during the last 8,000 years when sea level rise has been
以一种富有成效和安全的方式，而不是试图把它挡在外面。所以，你说的这很迷人，因为在某种程度上，你是在说，认为我们可以克服这种失败的隐喻在某种程度上可能是错误的隐喻，在某种程度上，那场战斗可能几乎已经输了。没错，海洋在过去22,000年里一直在上升。我们只是处于一个缓慢的时期。我们在过去8,000年海平面上升非常缓慢的时候发明了整个城市的概念，
very slow. So it can go really quickly, and we are concerned that in their new phase, it may go faster than it ever has in the last 20,000 years. We could be at the steepest part of the curve. So the idea of fighting that as if it's a war and you're keeping the enemy out, the Dutch used to think of it that way and try to guarantee safety to their citizens by keeping all of the seawater out, protecting them from all storm floods.
所以它可能会变得非常快，我们担心在新的阶段，它可能会比过去20,000年中的任何时候都快。我们可能正处于曲线最陡峭的部分。所以，像打仗一样去对抗它，把敌人挡在外面，荷兰人过去就是这样想的，并试图通过把所有的海水挡在外面，保护他们免受所有风暴洪水的侵袭，来保证公民的安全。
But even the Dutch have said, well, you know what? Maybe that's not realistic and we need to figure out how to live with water. And that's become the slogan of the Dutch effort to adapt is living with water, doing more floating housing, more artificial ponds that kind of make room for water and allow people to live around and even on the water. Adaptation is going to be very difficult and very expensive. Many countries will not be able to afford what the Dutch have done. They are going to have to come up with their own solutions, their own adaptations, but
但即使是荷兰人也说，好吧，你知道吗？也许那是不现实的，我们需要弄清楚如何与水共存。这已经成为荷兰适应努力的口号，即“与水共存”，进行更多的浮动住房，更多的人工池塘，为水腾出空间，让人们在水周围甚至在水上生活。适应将是非常困难和昂贵的。许多国家将无法负担荷兰所做的事情。他们将不得不提出自己的解决方案，自己的适应方式，但
starting sooner rather than later, can reduce the harm and reduce the costs. Christina says the challenge here is not just about economics or politics. It's also psychological. Adaptation involves accepting a certain measure of defeat. American audiences respond very poorly to the word retreat. Americans don't retreat. in a word retreat, Americans don't retreat. To American years, retreats, smacks of cowardice and capitulation. And at a deeper level, retreat calls on us to accept that there might be towns and cities we cannot save. Yes, there may be population centers we can protect with levees and pumps.
早做总比晚做好，可以减少伤害并降低成本。克里斯蒂娜说，这里的挑战不仅仅是经济或政治问题。它也是心理上的。适应涉及接受一定程度的失败。美国观众对“撤退”这个词反应非常糟糕。美国人不撤退。对美国人来说，撤退带有懦弱和投降的味道。在更深层次上，撤退要求我们接受可能有一些城镇和城市是我们无法拯救的。是的，可能有一些人口中心我们可以用堤坝和泵来保护。
There may be fortifications we can build to guard against storms, but adaptation might mean there are some areas that cannot be saved. Which politician is willing to tell her constituents? It's time to pull up stakes and run. In the United States, we don't really allow even grief. So, how do you imagine the losses of land and, you know, places that our parents lived and that we've always imagined living in? We wanted our children to live in. There's a lot of grief in that. And grief isn't really accepted in American culture.
可能有一些防御工事我们可以建造来抵御风暴，但适应可能意味着有些地区是无法拯救的。哪位政治家愿意告诉她的选民？是时候收拾行李逃跑了。在美国，我们甚至不允许悲伤。所以，你如何想象土地的损失，你知道，我们父母居住的地方，我们一直想象居住的地方？我们希望我们的孩子居住的地方。这其中有很多悲伤。而悲伤在美式文化中并不真正被接受。
Yet, if we fail to do that psychological work, if we fail to talk honestly about what can and cannot be done, if we fail to be realistic about our options, Christina warns that natural disasters will not be the only things keeping us up at night. Unless we come up with ways to adapt in place in a way that gives us some stability for, let's say, 30 to 50 years at a time, then we create tens of millions of climate refugees, maybe hundreds of millions, and that, I think, means international conflict. That means war. So I think that's better to imagine adapting in place and reducing
然而，如果我们不能完成那种心理工作，如果我们不能诚实地谈论什么可以做，什么不能做，如果我们不能对我们的选择保持现实，克里斯蒂娜警告说，自然灾害将不是唯一让我们彻夜难眠的事情。除非我们想出办法在原地适应，并给我们带来30到50年的稳定性，否则我们就会制造出数千万甚至数亿的气候难民，我认为这意味着国际冲突。这意味着战争。所以我认为最好想象在原地适应并减少
our CO2 than it is to imagine either the deaths or the migrations of tens of millions of people that's unacceptable. Rather than deny what is inevitable, seeing climate change realistically might allow us to harness ingenuity and innovation. Reframing the conversation from the language of pessimism and catastrophe to the language of optimism and creativity might be a way to transform the challenges we face and get more people to realize they are not just part of the problem, but part of the solution. It's really about thriving, not vanquishing a foe. How can we thrive? With what agreements, with what physical systems, how do we look forward to a culture where people can be creative and happy and enjoy living with water? Water is beautiful.
我们的二氧化碳排放，而不是想象数千万人死亡或迁移，那是不可接受的。与其否认不可避免的事情，现实地看待气候变化可能会让我们利用独创性和创新。将对话从悲观和灾难的语言转向乐观和创造性的语言，可能是一种改变我们面临的挑战并让更多人意识到他们不仅是问题的一部分，而且是解决方案的一部分的方法。这实际上是关于繁荣，而不是战胜敌人。我们如何才能繁荣？通过什么协议，什么物理系统，我们如何期待一种人们可以创造、快乐并享受与水共存的文化？水是美丽的。
can be creative and happy and enjoy living with water. Water is beautiful. It's really about believing that there's going to be a way where we can have compassion for each other and we can be resourceful. We can be more resourceful together than alone. And we can be brave. We've used the frames of Dunkirk and Normandy in the story to make a point. The world is not focused remotely enough on the challenge of adaptation. To the extent we focus on adaptation, we are usually reactive.
可以创造、快乐并享受与水共存。水是美丽的。这实际上是相信有一种方式，我们可以彼此同情，我们可以足智多谋。我们在一起比单独一人更能发挥聪明才智。我们可以勇敢。我们在故事中使用了敦刻尔克和诺曼底的框架来表达一个观点。世界对适应挑战的关注还远远不够。在某种程度上，我们关注适应，通常是反应性的。
We think about adaptation after the hurricane strikes, after the island is submerged, after forest fires have burned through half a state. Even then, we don't do remotely enough. People continue to flock to the coast to places that are going to be severely affected by climate change. Even those who believe that climate change is real, tell themselves, it won't affect me. I'll sell my home near the sea before it's too late. Normandy Talk helps such denial. It allows us to imagine that if we all made just a few more sacrifices, there is a way to prevent catastrophe.
我们在飓风袭击后、岛屿被淹没后、森林大火烧毁了半个州之后才考虑适应。即使在那时，我们做得也远远不够。人们继续涌向海岸，涌向那些将受到气候变化严重影响的地方。即使是那些相信气候变化是真实存在的人，也会告诉自己，它不会影响我。我会在为时已晚之前卖掉我海边的房子。诺曼底式的谈话有助于这种否认。它让我们想象，如果我们每个人都多做一点牺牲，就有办法防止灾难。
Now, to be clear, there is a compelling scientific and moral case to be made for mitigation. The less carbon we emit, the more we can delay the harmful consequences of climate change. Ice will melt more slowly. Seas will rise more gradually. Storms and fires will be less frequent and less destructive. Some significant harms from climate change are already inevitable, but the things we do today can have an enormous impact on the lives of people 100, 200 or 500 years from now.
现在，明确一点，在减缓气候变化方面，有一个令人信服的科学和道德理由。我们排放的碳越少，我们就越能推迟气候变化的有害后果。冰川融化会更慢。海平面上升会更平缓。风暴和火灾会更少、破坏性更小。气候变化带来的一些重大危害已经是不可避免的，但我们今天所做的事情可以对100年、200年或500年后人们的生活产生巨大的影响。
The truth is we shouldn't have to choose between adaptation and mitigation. They are both important. We must save millions of people around the world who will be displaced or affected by climate change in the near future. And we must limit the planetary harm we pass down to future generations. As Christina told me, we need to walk and chew gum at the same time. But across the world, governments are not doing remotely enough on either front, let alone
事实是，我们不应该在适应和减缓之间做出选择。它们都很重要。我们必须拯救世界各地数百万将在不久的将来因气候变化而流离失所或受到影响的人。我们必须限制我们留给后代的全球性危害。正如克里斯蒂娜告诉我的，我们需要边走边嚼口香糖。但在世界各地，政府在两个方面做得都远远不够，更不用说
both. Meanwhile, the storms and fires and floods keep coming. To paraphrase that warning on the side view mirrors of cars, the future is closer than you think. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
两者兼顾了。与此同时，风暴、火灾和洪水不断袭来。套用汽车后视镜上的警告，未来比你想象的要近。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Ryan Katz、Kristen Wong、Laura Quarelle、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero today is Sarah Miller. She wrote a wonderful article some years ago. It was titled, Heaven or High Water. It's about our collective psychological denial of the realities of climate change. The article is funny and terribly scary at the same time, and I highly recommend you track it down and read it. Sarah's writing led me to Christina Hill. Thank you Sarah. Special thanks this week to researchers Peter Blumin and Christina Halber, who helped us understand the science of climate change.
我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们今天的无名英雄是Sarah Miller。几年前她写了一篇精彩的文章。标题是《天堂还是高水位》。它是关于我们对气候变化现实的集体心理否认。这篇文章既有趣又非常可怕，我强烈建议你找出来读一读。Sarah的写作引导我找到了克里斯蒂娜·希尔。谢谢你，Sarah。本周特别感谢研究人员Peter Blumin和Christina Halber，他们帮助我们理解了气候变化的科学。
If you liked this episode, please be sure to share it with a few friends, maybe listen together and chat about what it means afterwards. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与几个朋友分享，也许可以一起听，并在之后聊聊它的意义。我是Shankar Vedantam。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。